[Musique]
je connais ma mission
c'est un message pour William duquens
bruceck burn monsieur Dukan monsieur
Duquesne je vous appelle suite aux
lettres et vous m'avez envoyé je sais
pas très bien comment vous m'avez trouvé
vos lettres constituent à harcèlement
s'il vous plaît n'envoyez plus
c'est pas vous qui avez écrit ce livre
La machine infernale je m'en souviens
parce qu'il les avait retiré des
étagères à cause de notre ville à cause
de lui que j'ai jamais écrit de deuxième
livre
[Musique]
très controversé la machine infernale
d'une centaine chez moi c'est un beau
livreur un break rouge on a que ce type
des véhicules au sein de notre
entreprise qui êtes-vous et ce type qui
a lu votre livre le tireur de nocesville
il est dans une prison de haute sécurité
au Nouveau Mexique c'est pas lui il faut
arrêter de m'écrire vous comprenez alors
vous lui voulez quoi William duques je
vous le dirai une fois que vous m'aurez
dit ce qu'il vous voulez il voulait
savoir si j'avais vu la même chose que
lui dans ce livre il y aura un message
caché dans ce roman à la portée de tous
la raison ne peut comprendre la démence
je me trompe rousse j'ai des tas de
questions à propos de ton livre je sais
où on en est Monsieur Ducasse fin de
l'acte 2 n'est-ce pas le moment où le
protagoniste atteint ses limitée
personne qui pourrait vous en vouloir et
vous faire ça
[Musique]
je peux attendre
si vous ne savez pas les manipuler ce
seront eux qui vous manipuleront